so these are jellied eels ills in jelly
journals and these are ill with no jelly
like loads of eels drawers of ills hold
on to your seats this might get a bit
weird so we got this giant jiggly bowl
of jellied eels from this guy my name is
John Childers I work for Michiel supply
and Billy fake fish market we supply
live eels to the catering trade public
I've been selling eels for three years
since I left school I was at the lovely
Umbria these are all farmed from Holland
but if they like the Rolls Royce of the
dililili they were very very slippery by
Sunday afternoon back in the 18th
century London's River Thames was
crawling details nowadays John is one of
the last few ill suppliers in London so
John why were there so popular you need
to speak to one of the older fish
mongers for that oh okay then I'm 72
years old and I eels everyday perfect
so Frank of Bradley's fish supply what
made them so popular back then so those
days it was it was no brainer everybody
at jellied eels it was an easy source to
get and very simple you put a hook out
and they catch their self eels are
really edible and they were full of
goodness that people didn't realize it
then but they were they were eating a
real good product and we didn't have
Indian Chinese takeaway kabobs
everything else so it was a it was a
source of food so how do you make them
quite easy to prepare to head off guts
out chopped in pieces then we cook them
the process of cooking is more of an art
you need them to be very soft if you go
past being soft or you've got is mash
thanks Frank
so pie shop owner Kane what do they go
well with jellied eels and students are
very traditional with pie mash and
liquor in the East End the London so you
know it's not for everybody
the world is changing a little bit you
do either like and will hate them
probably in the old days we will go
through
maybe 50 or $60 of ills a week probably
now we might do 10 or 12 so if you think
about food around the world you think
about Paris and never get New York you
think about the pizzas the New York
cheesecakes that's what they're
synonymous for London the traditional
food in London is punishment that is a
staple diet and the taste
it's like eating basically a chunky
white fish he must feel ah it must be me
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh